The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
Remember that our program is mostly funded
by members who sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We have way too much to talk about today for
me to filibuster for five minutes about membership.
But I really do appreciate everybody who signed
up this month.
And I encourage you to grab a membership at
Join Pakman Dotcom last week.
Unfortunately, and this really is tragic.
Last week may actually not be the craziest
week of Donald Trump's presidency.
It may be this week in what is effectively
the last eight or nine days of Donald Trump's
presidency leading up to next Wednesday's
swearing in of President Joe Biden.
There are new reports out about Donald Trump's
plans for this week, and it appears as though
it is going to be an absolutely insane week
from Donald Trump.
Donald Trump, of course, now suspended permanently
from Twitter, as we will talk about in a little
bit.
Donald Trump, after denouncing his own vice
president last Wednesday, at least as of last
night, hasn't even spoken to Mike Pence.
And he is considering what can he do in this
last week?
And every possibility is completely bonkers.
Remember that discussion about a possible
pardon in advance, a blanket pardon in advance
of his own family members?
It is increasingly looking like Donald Trump
is going to do that in the next eight or nine
days.
Maybe by the time you listen to this clip,
some of those pardons will already have started.
There is still the consideration of Donald
Trump pardoning himself, in fact.
And I know that every time I talk about this,
people write in and say a president cannot
pardon themselves.
Remember that we've gone into the legality,
the legal scholarship on this.
There are divergent opinions as to whether
a president can or cannot pardon themselves.
But the most important thing is that it has
not been tested in court ever.
And it is certainly possible that a president
can pardon themselves.
And there is that possibility as well.
Trump absolutely furious with Twitter and
other social media platforms for banning him
either temporarily, indefinitely or for life
up to and including Twitter, which we will
talk about.
There is the idea that Donald Trump is looking
to do something to big tech over the next
eight days that he has left, nine days that
he has left in office.
We don't know exactly what that will be, but
it very well may be absolutely out of this
world.
And then Donald Trump also reportedly planning
to go to the border in Alamo, Texas, in principle
tomorrow, Tuesday, to make a big deal, I guess,
out of his major success of building the wall.
Not that at this point I need to remind you,
but this is yet another broken promise.
Fortunately, it's a broken promise because
it was going to be a waste of time and money
to begin with.
But Donald Trump promised that by the end
of his first term, we would have a wall between
the US Mexico border on the US Mexico border
across the entire border.
And of course, what we've seen are modest
improvements to a few.
And I'm using the term improvements in terms
of what they are called from a construction
standpoint, modest improvements or renovations
to a few hundred miles of wall.
And that is actually something Donald Trump
has promised and failed.
Mexico didn't pay for it.
Trump didn't build the wall, but it's sort
of a last salvo.
He started by coming down the escalator and
telling us Mexico's not sending their best,
they're sending the criminals and et cetera.
And it looks like we are sort of coming full
circle with Donald Trump flying down to Texas
reportedly tomorrow to claim that he delivered
on that promise as well.
So there are a number of different what what
to call it.
There are a lot of really bad arguments being
made about what should or shouldn't happen
over the next week.
And of course, as we read about the insane
week that Donald Trump has planned, my mind
immediately goes to, of course, he should
be removed immediately by the 25th Amendment.
But that requires the Cabinet and Mike Pence
to act.
Every indication so far, as we mentioned earlier,
is Mike Pence is not interested in doing that.
So then you have to realize that impeachment
must happen.
Impeachment must happen.
And the fact that we are seeing some right
wingers saying it would be too divisive, there
are some on the right and left saying impeaching
or removing Trump would make him a martyr.
He's already both a dead and a martyr to his
own people.
The committed Trump sees Trump almost like
a God who can do no wrong and say no wrong.
And they already believe him to be a martyr
because as far as they see, he's been treated
so unfairly by the supposed fake news media.
He's been treated so unfairly by the Democrats
in all of this stuff.
They are crazy and violent already.
They are already attacking violently, as we
saw last week, because Trump lost the election
and.
Neither he nor they can come to grips with
reality, so as I said earlier, if removal
is warranted, you must remove.
If impeachment is warranted, you must impeach.
It doesn't appear as though removal will happen.
So it must be impeachment.
And as I said before, taking swift legal action
against Donald Trump and the insurrectionist
riot, riotous terrorists and every state and
local Republican member who supported this,
that is the best way to stop this movement.
The idea of it would be divisive to impeach
again.
That doesn't stop the movement, my friends.
That's a failure.
It's nothing.
It's not it's not actually anything.
Trump should already be gone.
And that's why I support another impeachment,
which we discussed earlier.
Waiting even one more day could spell disaster.
Look at the insanity of what he's planning
over the next week and then consider the urgency
of what's going on.